من عمان الى فلسطين افتتح موقع تصوير
مسلسل فلسطيني ام الياسمين في بلده قرب
رام الله في قصر اثري شيده قبل 300 عام
حيث سيتم في المكان تصوير مسلسل عن حب
زمنيه للبلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس
ويتفرقين الانتداب البريطاني والخلافات
العائليه في المدينه المتابعه
قصه سحويل في بلده عبوين كربه رام الله
اختيره مكانا لتصوير مسلسل ام الياسمين
لان جغرافيا المكان تشبه الى حد بعيد
جغرافيا مدينه نابلس قبل مئه عام
بدكاكينها وزيها التقليدي وعاداتها
وتقاليدها
[موسيقى]
مسلسل ام الياسمين هو عمل فلسطيني يتحدث
عن مدينه نابلس من عام 1929 حتى عام 1935
ينقل حياه البيئه النابلسيه بكامل
تفاصيلها في تلك الفتره حاولنا نصنع هذا
موقع التصوير لحتى نجسد الحياه النابلسيه
في تلك الفتره
[موسيقى]
فيهم الياسمين الحقيقه اول مره اكون بدور
انسان شويه على البركه
اصيبت كل عائلته او توفيت عن بكرت ابيها
وبقي هو
فاصيب عقليه الى حد ما لكن تنبع من هذا
اللي على البركه انواع من الحكمه احيانا
يعني من افواه المجانين احيانا تنطلق
الكلمات المعبره والكلمات الحقيقيه اللي
بتعبر عن حال الناس
[موسيقى]
الانتداب البريطاني او السياسه ليست طاغيه
على احداث مسلسل ام الياسمين الذي يتناوله
بشكل خاص القضايا الاجتماعيه من ابرزها
الخلافه على الميراث من موقع تصوير مسلسل
ام الياسمين في بلده عبوين قرب رام الله
خالد القاسم العربيه
2 1 اكشن يا صلاح العالميه احلى صباح